um i was reading this article and i sent
it to ben about children being medicated
uh and i took adderall briefly when i
was a youngster in um
uh eighth grade and it just you know i
don't know i just got a dry mouth it
didn't really work i mean i got a little
speedy
but you know the grades didn't go up so
i think my parents were like okay let's
not do it anymore um but this is
interesting this teen was pre and by the
way i think people need medic medication
so don't this isn't one of those things
where i say no one needs medication i
think certain people need to be on their
medication i have them in my family and
i know
but there is you know this teen here was
prescribed tense psychiatric drugs
uh
she's not alone one morning in the fall
of 2017 renee smith a high school
freshman on long island new york
interesting
could not get out of bed overwhelmed by
the prospect of going to school in the
following days her anxiety mounted into
despair i should have been happy she
later wrote but i cried screamed begged
the universe or whatever godly power to
take away the pain
of a thousand men that was trapped
inside my head
intervention for depression and anxiety
came not from the divine but from the
pharmaceutical industry
the following spring a psychiatrist
prescribed prozac the medication
uh we all associate with you know
depression um however she kept taking it
the effect dissipated she was uh
prescribed an additional antidepressant
affects her
um
[Music]
during 2021 the year she graduated she
was prescribed
seven
drugs
these included one for seizures and
migraines which neither she didn't have
any of either one of those but the drug
can also be used to stabilize mood and
another to dull the side effects of the
other medications although it's mainly
used for schizophrenia she felt better
on some days and deeply sad on others
her senior yearbook photo shows her
smiling broadly quote but i feel
terrible that day said miss smith who is
now 19 and attends a local community
college i've gotten good at wearing a
mask
um
she had come to exemplify medical
practice common among her generation the
simultaneous use of multiple heavy-duty
psychiatric drugs
psychiatrists and other clinicians
emphasize the psychiatric drugs properly
prescribed can be vital in stabilizing
adolescents and saving the lives of
suicidal teens but these experts caution
such medications are too readily doled
out often as an easy alternative to
therapy that families cannot afford or
find so that's an interesting
that's really an interesting thing
people do we have better help this week
i don't think we do actually
would have been nice
well anyway
for a waste
people can't get therapy and they can't
afford it and the doctors are just
cramming pills down the throats of the
you know a lot of people
every now and then you'll meet a kid
that you it needs to be immediately
drugged and you can tell and i've you
know i have friends with children where
the child is like
and you go
lock it in the cage
you go put the drugs in it and lock it
in a cage because some people have kids
that have problems you see big problems
okay like my you know one of my friend's
kids like he was on his tippy toes a lot
he would just you meet a kid like that
they're on their tippy toes they're
going like this and i'm like
there you go all right that's that's not
going to get solved by a catch in the
front yard right
catch isn't going to help that like
throwing a ball that's not going to help
that i didn't even know what it was but
on the tippy toes and then he would go
like this he got
so
in those rare instances when it's not
going to be solved with the game of
catch or some wheat bread
it's not solved with taking away some
ice cream
it's a real
problem
you got to sedate the children drug them
up
put the drugs in them and put them in
the cage because they are a problem
hyperactive
i don't know but you you meet them every
now and then you're you're at a party
it's a nice barbecue
and then you know it's like the the it's
the running of the bulls the barn door
opens and out comes like oh my god what
the [ __ ] is this
and i don't know how it happened or what
happened
but the kid's a [ __ ] lunatic and you
go if this kid's not medicated they will
kill
somebody or themselves they'll burn
something down they're a liability
some kids are a liability and they need
to be drugged because
they're [ __ ] nuts
and i'm not a doctor and that's not the
clinical term but that's what happens
you've seen some of these kids right
yeah i mean they they have hard times
understanding what reality is you
explain to them that roblox isn't real
it's not real life they're like what do
you mean but i'm in the game my friends
are that's everybody my point is when
they're actually that's not that's not
what i mean
what i mean is not a kid who's quietly
playing a video game who thinks it's
real that's fine think it's real just
shut up
my point is a kid who's like yeah yeah
yeah
you wanna make my dog you wanna make my
dog you want to meet my dog you want to
meet my dog you want to be my
you know what i mean just where it's
like it's like okay okay i'll meet your
dog later i'll meet your dog later i've
already met your dog i've already met
get the [ __ ] going
those people need to be drugged some of
those kids cause some of those kids have
severe severe severe severe issues
but then there are those other kids in
school and you know the kids who are
like they're sad they're like i'm sad
and
i don't want it anymore like
i just don't want it
i'm so sad
and that's very sad so maybe give him a
little pill you give him a little blue
pill and go take a walk around the track
every town
has a little track that no one uses
you to take a walk around the track and
you have to take a little bit here's a
little pill here's a little pill you're
a little over dramatic
but you can't give them like 13 types of
medication
this is a problem
if you're really problem like if you
really have an issue where it's like
you're like i interested
and i'm not even i'm not trying to make
light of these things because people
have
they have genuine issues with depression
anxiety my mother is a schizophrenic i
call it schizophonic
because she's locked up now so it's just
fun she doesn't really bother anyone
key please
um but i get it i've had anxiety uh
myself i have problems with myself so
much of
this is about it's case by case you know
what i mean so there's people that are
severely
anxious and depressed that need
medication to function in life and then
there are people who are having
situational depression
who with cognitive behavioral therapy
they can improve their lives greatly
that includes changes in diet that
includes
maybe exercise that includes uh
moderation of drugs and or alcohol even
marijuana which everybody loves can
exacerbate underlying mental health
issues this is a fact right
so not everybody is a well-adjusted
person there's a lot of people i'm nuts
and everyone i know is nuts now we're
talented
you know but i'm telling you this
i know a lot of people that are need to
be on medication and i'm not saying that
medication is not good but i'm also
saying we are an over-medicated country
because there are certain like sometimes
i will eat something i shouldn't eat if
i eat like a big ice cream sundae i feel
happy i go oh i like it it feels good
but then you then it gets tied to god oh
i'm sad now
because the sugar high's over the high
the sugar is over the insulin crash
comes and then you're just like oh i
didn't know why did i do it and then
you're disgusted with yourself and
you're like i've been bad i've been bad
and you get upset and these negative
feelings and listen that can happen with
booze it can happen with food it can
happen with
any of these things right it can happen
with
laziness and sloth if you don't do it
you don't want to accomplish the things
you're doing
you then get disgusted and it becomes
this negative feedback loop where you're
like i'm a piece of [ __ ]
those are more situational things that
can be helped by lifestyle changes and
maybe some light medication tiny pill
walk around the track walk around at 7
30 at night have a jasmine tea get in
your bed nut
get in your bed and don't be a nut
now
there's some people that have deeper
problems than that where it's very bad i
had a friend named andrea
you know ready it's gonna be bad
you know
already it's going to be a bit i liked
andrea a lot she was a witch
a modern witch a wiccan
very mortal
and i liked andrew a lot
she was fun
she was sick
when i was a young person she was part
of my group my group included skaters
stoners goths
and uh drug dealers
um
i guess they were jocks i mean some of
them were you know they were it's not
they weren't being drafted but they some
of them were
you know able-bodied for sure physical
you know they would fight people and you
know brandish weapons when when you know
when need be
uh but we we had a big tent because
drugs and that's the beautiful things
about drugs that's why i recommend them
is that it is a great big tent
so
you would have and she was a lovely goth
girl
and she had a big um
um
knife
that she would cut herself with
not always
not always
not in front of you
you understand what i'm saying
she was a witch
she wore all black which i like i still
like that i still like that
she was a witch and she cut herself with
a big knife
and she had a lot of weed and we all
smoked weed with her and when she was
happy
when a depressed person is happy it's so
beautiful because they're not usually
happy she was manic i believe she was
manic depressive
and she would be so and we would laugh i
mean she was fun there were times
when we would just sit there
in the back of the library
because no one ever went long island to
the libraries and many people use drugs
there in the back of them because no one
goes to them
and and the people that work there don't
really pay attention because no one goes
to the lie unless you're like well like
an older like a guy like my uncle who
like goes in and he's like i want a book
on ulysses s grant and it's like hey
shut up
but you know like he'll go in and get a
book on ulysses s grant and then go go
and do the back room of his house and
drink
um
and but
we'd be sitting in the back of the
library
me her and my friend
and we would smoke pot and just start
laughing so hard nobody even said
anything
nobody even said anything
but it was just the fun
the humanity
and i believe she was in many mental
institutions like over and over again i
think she's dead now
i think she's dead but i don't here's
the thing i don't know
she might be alive she was a witch
and she had a big knife
my point is that
there are people out there with problems
you know what i mean
[Music]
i don't know if she's dead or not
if she's not dead don't dm me i don't
i don't play that game anymore i you
know i've moved on
but the point is
what i am saying and it's it's
it's hard to make this coherent but i
think the people out here that are
really connecting with it are
understanding what i mean
what i mean is that
this person
had problems but was a beautiful person
that i believe
i believe now is dead but i don't know
i don't know if she's dead or not
but
fun times
somebody would just giggle
like a like a like a hyena she would
cackle like a mad woman
and then run off with her knife into the
night
these are the memories
that if you if you're not making the
memories
i think she's dead
my point is that
you have to be careful with this
medication
because
had we medicated her earlier on
those beautiful moments that we
experienced
i don't know you know maybe they
wouldn't have been uh wouldn't have been
around
i i hate to sound selfish about it
but she was a fun person
we met her like twice
two or three times
[Laughter]
but when you're on drugs and you hang
out with somebody back then back in the
late 90s and early 2000s when you hung
out with somebody was like all day all
night people used to go out at 11 a.m
and get back at 5 00 a.m
all day all night there were different
drugs for different hours the gold it
was always nice weed in the golden hour
the gloaming the the sunset and then the
coke was at night but i mean you know
like or the hallucinogens or whatever
you were doing that night but you know i
was in the grocery store a few a few
minutes ago and the guy was talking to
his girlfriend i agree he's like yeah
they're all from the bay area they're
really into hallucinogens they're like
super smart guys i'm hanging out with
them this weekend they always get into
something [ __ ] crazy i'm like the
whole state's just drug addicts the
entire state is people that are just in
some form
of like psychosis it's crazy they're
really smart guys for the bay area
they're like super into hallucinogens
i'm hanging out with them this weekend
they always get into something
and she was like yeah
she goes i only go out on friday and
saturday nights and because that's
really like respectable that's like a
california conversation that's really
respectable you do i only got on friday
and saturday night that's really
respectable they're from the bay area
they're bringing their lucians